one year ago he learned the truth you're
a wizard Harry and his first year at
hogwarts school became legend you and so
for Harry Potter and his friends another
year begins lat e parts of menace the
education in the magical arts continues
sixties laughter you will mr. Finnegan
see what you make of them old rivalries
go stronger slithering still in your
seeker
and something in the school's dark past
will be awakened the Chamber of Secrets
has indeed been opened unless the
culprit is caught it is likely the
school will be closed Harry Potter must
go home Oh dare we are in trouble here's
the plan you disguise yourselves as
crowd and Goyle are we going to drink
that yes
hurry run excellent this year Warner
Brothers pictures presents how dare you
steal that car the next chapter of harry
potter
where the past will return and the
struggle for the future of Hogwarts will
begin
harry potter and the chamber secrets is
help mr. Potter will always be around to
save the day don't worry I will be